hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen ja heute meine liebe
zuschauer zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal wir beiden schauen uns
heute zu wahrscheinlich wir beiden wir
schauen uns heute zusammen einige
währungen aus dem asiatischen raum an
die komplett verrückt sind dass sie ist
die erste werbung die wir uns heute
zusammen anschauen einem man sieht schon
dass es eine burger king werbung ist der
typ will sich jetzt ein getränk noch
holen geht deswegen noch mal los da ist
ein anderer typ und der sieht jetzt den
burger das hat
[Musik]
ist
burger king
[Musik]
ich hab kein bock mehr auf die anwerbung
dass jetzt die zweite werbung ich weiß
nicht worum es hier geht
wir sehen kinder die baseball spielen
und einen hund und jetzt kommt ein
anderer hund und jetzt stehen da es geht
um chips das war die ganze zeit eine
chips werbung was ich auch stark finde
ist dass man bei diesem grund hier
einfach den stock sich der in seinem po
ist mit dem herumgetragen wir das ist
nicht völlig kein echter hund die
komplette werbung handelt einfach um
irgend ein baseballspiel allerdings
werden chips von einem hund irgendwie
beworben
ich dachte wirklich die whopper wir
haben mehr komisch aber der hund ob
gerade alles das hier ist eine werbung
die mir juli noch geschickt hat meinte
sie dass sich darauf auf jeden fall auch
reagieren soll
da ist eine person die glaube ich maler
ist so wie ich das sehe weil sein ganzes
t shirt volles mit maler klecksel hier
auch sein gesicht ist voll mit farbe und
[Musik]
er wird ihnen die waschmaschine gesteckt
also es ist anscheinend eine waschmittel
[Musik]
er war
ja also diese frau hier macht gerade
wäsche und dann kommt der maler an der
gerade anscheinend gegen die wände
gemalt hat und sich selbst auch
irgendwie ein bisschen angemalt hat die
dame packt ihn dann allerdings hochkant
in die waschmaschine und dann kommt er
hier was ist was was geht ab bei denen
dahinten das hier ist die nächste
werbung da liegt ein junge auf dem boden
und hat hunger und cremig
das ist keine theorie vorgestellt wird
glaube ich hier geht es um ein getränk
bzw eine soße und da kommt einfach ihnen
eine frau ausgetanzt alles klar
auf jeden fall logisch und aus ihrem hut
kommt jetzt diese und aus dem käse hielt
eine person die rumschreit und
wenn ich das im fernsehen sehen würde
dann hätte ich nicht den gedanken in
meinem kopf von wegen hey die soße
brauche ich sondern vielmehr ich hätte
heute nacht nur albträume keine ahnung
was hier jetzt wieder abgeht ms sieht
auf jeden fall ein bisschen neu aus und
ich glaube es ist eine werbung
[Musik]
das war eine werbung für kaugummi warum
bleibt dann sind überdimensionale
platzte durch tokio das ist jetzt
irgendeine werbung wo eine frau ein
[Musik]
also es ist anscheinend werbung
das sind irgendwelche kaubonbons und die
werben damit dass diese mädels das mit
dem bund weitergeben oder was marketing
level japan keine ahnung was hier schon
wieder abgeht das fällt irgendetwas vom
himmel runter und wir sehen komplett
echte affen kostüme die essen irgendwas
und nichts konnte also
wenn ich die werbung mal interpretieren
soll als zuschauer würde ich mir denken
hey ich bin jetzt ein affe aber wenn ich
dass es endlich trocken
[Musik]
wir sind zwei personen die mit einander
reden ich verstehe es halt nicht weil
japanische kollegen hund ist da jetzt
angekommen und sie wirft ihren schuh auf
den hund und wir jetzt auch noch gibt
um was geht es in dieser werbung
[Musik]
erreicht
das war eine sushi werbung wen wollt ihr
denn verarschen ich weiß nicht ob ich
das ganze einfach nicht checke weil ich
nicht in diesem raum wohne oder jemals
dort irgendwie in japan oder keine
ahnung wo zu besuch war und mit der
kultur vertraut bin et cetera pp aber
meiner westlichen anschauung nach ist
das komplett am thema vorbei ist
verbogen das hier ist die nächste
werbung
es werden irgendwelche flaschen gezeigt
und in der flasche ist es anscheinend
minus 196 grad und der typ steht im
supermarkt schauten die fleischereien
und sieht einfach nur wie diese leute
das hätte bei mir einfach einen
gegenteiligen effekt wenn ich sehen
würde dass ein typ in eine fleischerei
geguckt und darin sehen wir die kleinen
männchen und tanzen winter doch nicht
kaufen egal
hier haben wir eine raupe die einen ast
hochklettert zum ersten mal englische
untertitel
und zwar suchen die beiden nach tee und
gehen dahin und der sohn sagt jetzt ich
kann nicht mehr warten ich laufe auf der
anderen seite her
wir haben unser gold sagt jetzt andere
wir wollen jetzt nach oben unbedingt und
er nimmt jetzt sein sohn auf die
schultern und ist jetzt ganz der kleine
weint
und der gibt jetzt die raupe macht stößt
jetzt irgendwas aus in die nase vor dem
typen so dass er das bin ja ich will
hier heute würde diese werbung scheint
ein wenig neuer zu sein die qualität ist
nämlich ziemlich gut
sie schmeißt ihre kette weg die dame sie
streicht sich durch das haar schaut
neben der kamera her macht sich nur
einen zopf hat auch hohe schuhe an
schreit jetzt allerdings los und haut
mit ihrem korb demand platten uns keine
jungtiers und übertragungswagen und die
dass ein hund im weltall
[Musik]
jetzt ist eine werbung anscheinend eine
es ist eine werbung für eine bank wir
sind eine seriöse bank wie kriegen wir
den geschäftskunden akquirieren senken
und den 23
die aber keine ahnung worum es hier geht
da ist eine frau und die steckt in der
wand drin fest und kommt nicht raus und
der mann hier steckt auch drin und die
beiden auch ich habe nicht verstanden um
was es ging das hier ist halt auch so
eine richtige japanische werbung ich
glaube das ist für diese verwies oder
momo oder kanal um die teile heißen
meine schwester draußen legen aber
genauso habe ich mal eine japanische
werbungen vorgestellt nicht so verrückt
wie die anderen waren sondern einfach so
witzig komplett und alles war
durcheinander gut meine lieben freunde
ich würde sagen wir haben es ja schon so
einigen schwarzen im heutigen
angeguckt allerdings kommen wir nun zu
letzten werbung die wir uns heute
zusammen anschauen werden werbung wo ein
fußballplatz gezeigt wird das ist das
ist wenn man nicht bei somit fahren wo
es geht
google zeigt er kann zwischen er kann
erhöhten jetzt wieder hochgezogen von
aliens von links die lose herum was geht
es da und jetzt kommt der anbieter als
kind ich hatte albträume von diesem
scheiß goethe warum denkt sich dann
anscheinend so viele japanische kinder
3ds aber die chips wo sich fressen
anderer stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde ganz viele von euch haben unter
meine letzten reaction sind die
kommentare geschrieben kann du musst dir
unbedingt mal komische japanische
werbungen angucken das habe ich jetzt
heute getan und meine damen und herren
ja die waren wirklich alles sehr komisch
scheint sie noch weitere verrückte
werbungen kennt auf die ich unbedingt
reagieren sollen oder falls ich etwas
komplett anderes reagieren sollen
schreibt mir das gerne unten in die
kommentare last einen daumen hoch bei
dem video david euch gefallen hat und
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der lupus und dadurch verpasste
keine videos werden
[Musik]